[Music]
action oh nice thank you
excuse me yeah more it was a burp
version of the chamber whoa
well anyway I was gonna talk about how
Apple has confirmed that it has slowed
down some models as the age which we had
talked about in the past they got in
trouble for [ __ ] torquing planned
obsolescence right what what what they
call it planned obsolescence
oh I was like who's Glenn obsolete since
he said Planned Parenthood no Planned
Parenthood looks like what are these
words that decay yeah
and so now recently Apple has agreed to
pay a 500 million dollar settlement to
the lawyers and we all get 35 I mean
yeah 25 bucks they're still talking my
[ __ ] every that's why I try my best to
not do the update thing and I go oh
remind me next week remind me tomorrow
and then did you know that if you leave
your computer on with the plugged on it
automatically [ __ ] you're not there
after that it's slow down my
[ __ ] MacBook Pro I shot read
about this but I just guessed that
number because there's what always
happens with class-action lawsuit I
think the lawyers get the money we all
get [ __ ] how come we can't sue over
that can we sue the lawyers yeah I want
to see the lawyer as we can that sounds
kind of hard to do with the public
difficulties why are we defending
ourselves cuz if we're defending
ourselves against lawyers we might know
yeah we might find a really Sharky
lawyer who wants to [ __ ] other lawyers
but then isn't the lawyer gonna get the
money so then whatever we're fighting
for the lawyers just no man who's on
second I don't [ __ ] know anything we
need to better call Saul that guy will
fight for us
better call Saul or Johnnie Cochran oh
no Johnnie Cochran I was gonna say I'm
their age Parker looks decrepit oh
you'll fight for you have you guys seen
his son he looks older than years Larry
is Parker's son because you've been
doing the commercials with the sign now
one point you know the story that's
crazy
I like when auto dealerships have their
whole family in the shot like I give a
[ __ ]
go see how oh yeah so anyway so iPhone
users in the United States are entitled
to a payment of $25 if they owned an
iPhone 6 6 plus 6 s 6s plus 7 7 plus or
7s what about X for every single one do
you [ __ ] do do we get one for the 6 to
7 to 7 plus of course you can buy a new
doll Goldie I can't buy a whole they're
like $75 bra this whole time I thought
we were like on to some like conspiracy
and and and to find out that we were
right that's crazy
that's dude doesn't that's what always
happens later on evite that you're right
yeah the cars we're doing that really
what cars they're slowing their and
obsolescence of cars they were doing
that the most is Glenn obsolescence the
idea of being right that you you design
technology that needs to be reborn right
my students all make more money yeah
true so you're saying the cars would
like the new tech in them they would
like [ __ ] it up so you'd have to go in
and pay to get it hey they design the
night like that like it's made to last
like two hundred thousand miles the
radiator blow is part of their business
model that's why I remember it was like
it was like All American cars they just
break down on you right so your lease
yep well leasing is its own scam for at
least maybe Donna can with the lease
well you don't I mean you're putting
[ __ ] tons of equity into something that
you don't ultimately own it only
benefits business owners Corinne yeah
yeah yeah but it's funny getting new car
everything and you pay a premium
actually you got out of rate if you're
buying it but but then you have this car
that you just gonna have forever yeah
Wow that you can sell later trust me I
know the whole [ __ ] auto industry is
a scam in a way like for because of that
way what are your thoughts on the the
programs like for it I think has one
where they keep a monthly service fee
and then you get your [ __ ] Ford
Carter III think all of this won't
matter within 10 years because you'll
literally just use teleportation no oh I
wish
please know it'll be like it'll be like
like uber but it's your own car and you
pay for a certain amount to use the sick
cars and you can pay for like sicker and
sicker cars right but eventually they'll
get the point where you just get dropped
off a place then your car goes in parks
and maybe goes and picks up other people
or whatever and sharing cars we would
all be sharing cars but you get us know
you get a certain car of a certain
program that's maybe your car for the
month or whatever and it's it's all part
of a payment plan and then you just hit
the de santé like sanitization know it's
your car it's your car
but it but it put it for that amount of
time and then they go have it cleaned or
whatever the [ __ ] at the end of month
they have cars just parked all over like
Europe like an Airbnb car yeah good
remember you know we all pay for parking
now up and out the ass especially in LA
that's gonna be gone in ten years
hopefully they will be gone I promise
you well the traffic be gone - please no
well well okay so if we have ignited not
driving cars and they can drive within a
quarter distance of them of each other
while going 70 miles an hour cause
they're all robots very crazy it's gonna
happen believe what he's saying like no
no that's not what happily was about
well it's similar it's similar what the
thing is Hyperloop only for Tesla Z's
but it's not intended to be eventually
one day they would open up to everybody
for a feat so it's not a freeway it's a
feat wait right now Tesla Tesla toll is
a toll wait I know I like few way better
yeah that's true with the best tracks
yeah yeah anyway this um I don't [ __ ]
you know get ready dude your car will go
park itself somewhere you don't even
know where it Park you sound crazier
watch yeah you sound like gonna be tight
I rather rely my horse it already been I
don't trust nothing that don't have a
brain
exactly last month Apple has received
and a very very hefty fine of 25 million
euros which comes out to about 27
million dollars from France's consumer
watchdog for the exact same issue so
hopefully now Apple is
they did it all [ __ ] please mice
computer still slow and that money is
nothing double take it [ __ ]
that's nothing baby we made billions
your computer slow too big time man
I'm trying to figure out the reasons why
hmm have you tried wiping yeah we clean
it I complete like they'll eat it like a
Giga [ __ ] I mean a hundred gigs a [ __ ]
and it's a lot better okay I'll do it to
your cookies as well maybe a disk in a
deep fraggin and go yet defragment
defrag is yeah it's a stupid monitor
yeah defrag and these flank defied it so
that's a bit of funny you disco defrag
in man you did that to your PC you
cleaned it up where your computer's full
of fragments it's mostly the poor new
ones
yep the horny ones you need to defrag
your cookies aw dude you cookies name I
got 50 million [ __ ] cookies from all
the porn oh wow
I don't watch porn on my laptop so there
I got a cookie up my phone you buddy
cookie jar your [ __ ] Cookie Monster
over there I might have to take a porn
break just gotta go to the safe ones bro
go to like you know can you do incognito
if you're like um I feel like the go-to
ones like you know porn you to you porn
porn huh
punch it isn't on there for Joe Sinek
sex is my [ __ ] my [ __ ] for a while
what's that well you know what it's it's
a blue X in xx but they change the
algorithm do it I don't like that [ __ ]
when you do the search they do the same
playlist you know what it is oh yeah you
search the C's then play with ok so
here's all the [ __ ] you search for it
stays on your homepage you go there it's
annoying it is annoying because because
you're faced with your shame yes what
does because like you you be like I'm a
very random porn mood person yeah you
don't want to come in you're just like
curious nothing like a new algorithm
[ __ ] commit to it yeah it's just there
when you go log well their merch store
is way better than I'm grown
no but like the cookie [ __ ] oh is I
don't care what's Gia's position on
pornos she doesn't mind she would rather
I like drag off to some porn then go
like get jerked off somewhere you know
so it's like whoa that's a slippery
slopes that's amore what about cam girls
cam girls I now think that would be
appropriate
Stu person is like a real-ass it's an
interaction yeah what about Holograms
mmm when she just take on [ __ ] the
vacuum cleaner I think she'd be pissed
cuz she's like she loves her vacuum yeah
where's you gotta separate vacuum
cleaner do you think you'd mind drinking
on ya gotta be cool station about it
cool also any cool cooling system I
recommend [ __ ] and sucking I wouldn't
do shot pack though shot backs are
pretty dangerous shut that shop vac chef
axe is where you got a term when you've
been [ __ ] the vacuum cleaner too long
you know you're kind of like well I'm
over it I need something to get me
harder so you got a shot that well I did
try sticking my dick inside of a vacuum
cleaner though when I was in junior high
because you see it on TV right
I tried [ __ ] WetJet but it didn't
really work out [ __ ] I was like it makes
more sense there is an age though that
you try sticking your dick in every
literally everything like if you didn't
do that I don't know if you had a great
childhood
I stuck my dick in a well and I was like
this isn't that good you know well yeah
wait you have there as wells where you
live yeah of course cool Irish
countryside oh well I tried to jerk off
with you know you also like experimental
things that drag off with and I tripped
off with bengay one time not why would
you do that's like tiger balm in your
eyes I know as a kid you castle oh maybe
maybe this will be a pleasurable
experience it was not immediately like
close seconds into it I was like wow
immediately washed icy hot and you can't
even really cool it down because you put
cold water it's burns in stadia stayed
for a while that's like getting sriracha
and jackin yourself off with chilly
let's see that's like wrapping your dick
with a tortilla and jackin off with
sriracha and putting sour cream in there
and thinking that that would feel better
huh stupid thing to do well you
shouldn't do it wonder why don't put in
the microwave either and put an edge
melt the cheese to it
flowers way softer I feel like when
girls experiment though it's so hot and
then when guys do it it's like the
[ __ ] disgust generous see dude yeah
[ __ ] it did you what did girls
experiment with like I rode my teddy
bear so cute adorable is my showerhead
and it felt good right simple that might
sound like the eraser I'm kind of green
onions so I could put it in the tortilla
though I'll put my dick in the my going
yeah I think guys just were creative
guys we're just curious we're like what
the work and I put my dick so curious
that now I wonder when Steve's little
scenario like would you eat it no you
don't eat it after you feed it to your
dog because you don't want it to go to
waste
feed your doggy watch the dog eating it
while you beat off no I think we can all
agree
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]